okay very good um i'm going to talk
about compressive sensing i'm part of uh
asmr research
we are a company that's very heavy and
software as well as hardware although
most people do know us for hardware but
there's also a complexity of algorithms
and
software in our company
so if you have had any experience with
photography you could have seen that you
can save images um that are very huge
when they come out of a camera
but you can
save them as a jpeg file very
effectively into just a few hundred
kilobytes so that's generally very good
thing says that compression is very
successful
but if you want to look at it from the
other way
from a sensor design so the view of
hardware which is also sometimes the sml
view
you see this kind of a failure of the
sensor design means that you've done too
much of measurement so can you do better
and here you can see the typical
workflow you measure something here you
sample it means that you go from analog
to digital then you have n numbers so
this is this huge file that comes out of
for example ccd of your dslr camera then
you can do compression to do a much
smaller size a few hundred kilobytes
store it and later reuse it and
decompression is generally not a very
difficult task
so
what happens in compressive sensing
is that now your hardware not only
measures but also compresses this means
that now the compressed number comes out
of your hardware
and instead of decompression you have to
do reconstruction which is a harder task
so you push the complexity from the
hardware
to the software and this has a lot of
applications inside the xml but also
outside for example for outside sml you
can think of internet of things where
you have cheap sensors
or sensors that have limitations in
their
bandwidth in their energy usage and what
you want to do
is
essentially
having a very
low energy
hardware
and then push all the complexity under
the construction side sometimes you want
your hardware also to do a basic
encoding for security this is an
encryption for security reason and
this is not in the scope of this talk
but compressive sensing also does that
so in short your hardware compresses
things pushes all the complicity to the
software side to do reconstruction
um
i want to give you an example this is an
example that really opened a whole new
host of applications for mri for
magnetic resonance imaging
uh so essentially for pediatric
applications children's are not very
cooperative uh
patients so they would move a lot that
would cause blur you cannot ask them to
hold their uh breath for two minutes you
can they can maybe do that for 10 20
seconds so shortening the time here you
use compressive sensing to shorten the
time how you do that mri measure in the
fourier domain so measures the fourier
coefficients of the image and you can
see that here i sub sample
uh essentially this fourier coefficients
and the low frequency you you sub sample
this is a 2d fourier
analysis and under
yeah under for the lower frequencies you
essentially
sample very densely and very sparsely
you sample the higher frequencies and
from this subsampled image you can
reconstruct the full mri image that's
the idea behind compressive sensing and
for that we actually can sometimes
change the hardware as well
is another example more abstract
so here you want to measure this
image l
and these numbers that are essentially
white these are the
the the non-zero numbers and everything
else is zero
you have m measurements so every column
is a measurement and what is a
measurement is multiplying this image
with a random pattern so this is the
result of the multiplication and summing
the number of white values so here your
four you get the measurement the
measured value is four so then you have
one two one two
and with this measured values so you do
just the inner product of your image
with a random pattern you can
reconstruct this l so now instead of
have a n by n image you would just have
five measured values and your hardware
can be designed sometimes to do this
step in one easy go so to multiply with
a random pattern
uh this is the notation i used
throughout this this talk name is the
number of measurements
k is the number of non-zero elements
and n is the number of pixels
so the problem dimension dimensionality
uh another example which may be
more
familiar for people in data sciences in
painting here
you can say that you have an image and
sub sampling the image itself and
filling up the
the missing values there's a well-known
practice called in painting this as you
do it mostly with deep neural networks
but
compressive sensing methods were one of
the first methods that have been used to
to solve this problem
so on the summary and outlook you trade
off the number of measurements with
higher software complexity
and more extensive calculation
uh this has business impact so you can
have simpler sensors that get the
possibility to compete with more complex
ones
um on the application you can have again
between two full to tenfold in terms of
number of measurements or time
there were different applications mri
i've shown internet of things so you can
have sensors that are limited bandwidth
and battery power
um and for example sometimes you can
have super resolution
again this is an application you know in
data science but also in hardware you
can have a
limit to your hardware to your
microscope which we call a bay or
nyquist limit and we can go beyond that
with these techniques
um
so what are the pillars of the
compressive sensing
the two main components of the
compressive sensing are the prior
knowledge and the type of measurement
that we have this incoherent measurement
if you remember the l image that was an
example of an incoherent measurement
where you measure essentially globally
by multiplying
your
signal with some random pattern and
summation so prior knowledge i'm going
to now explain
so we have signal f here
and the lower panel
the signal f in happens to have in the
fourier domain a sparse representation
now fourier analysis can be thought of
as a matrix multiplication so this is
your signal of interest and x is your
representation again sometimes you see
the word representation in data science
with a very complex
system
for example a deep auto encoder but it
can be as simple as a linear model pca
also gives you a representation so here
x is a fourier transform which happens
to be zero most of the time and now i'm
going to sample this signal f in
irregular grid and much lower than what
we call the nyquist rate so in signal
processing there is a dogma you have to
sample as fast or twice as fast as the
highest frequency and here you actually
go below that you you kind of measure
less and measure in an irregular grid
which is these red dots here these are
the measurement points of your signal if
now from these i want to reconstruct my
signal and go back to its representation
if i use this is just a linear system if
i use a least square estimate i get a
lot of nodes but if i use
the knowledge of that this signal was a
sparse
in the
frequency domain then i can exactly
reconstruct it so
even without noise you cannot exactly
reconstruct it this is the effect of
prior knowledge what you know about the
signal prior
um and this is the the key enabler of
this technology
um however
real signals are not sparse
so you need more advanced uh priors in
reality for example this is a wavelet
coefficient of a famous image called the
barbara
and you can see that this is heavy tail
this means it has a lot of very large
values there's not a spiked here so
there's a lot of meat values as well we
call this power law they occur most of
the time in nature they are very very
common
um
and
because of this reason you will see that
the sparse assumption is not that
successful and this is where data
science come into play modern techniques
have been used to come up with very
interesting priors
um and i'm going to talk
about at the end of the
um so how about the sensing problem so
this is my hardware and i want to send
something sensing in this stock there's
also a linear operation so f is the
signal of interest and y is what you
actually comes out of your hardware as a
sense value so if phi is sinusoid if you
multiply your signal or sinusoids you're
going to get fourier coefficients
if you phi is integrating over a certain
area of pixels you're going to get
pixelated images
and you can have super pixels there so
we can think of these as linear
transformations
so overall
measurement itself going from an image
to a measured value
is essentially done by a sensing matrix
the the the signal itself has a
representation which we often assume is
sparse now i can
create a relationship between my
measured value what comes out of my
hardware and my representation
and that is essentially just a linear
relation a equal to
phi psi
so again if i look into as an example
this was my image this is y
and the phi here is this random images
and here a equals to phi because the
image itself is a sparse so
the that is
essentially
no transformation involved to go to a
sparsity
so in a nutshell you have to just solve
linear systems
this system of equations is
fat and short this means that the number
of unknowns is much larger than the
number of equations so you don't have
enough equations
and to solve that you need extra
assumptions people used to use sparsity
to do that
that means that most of the elements of
x is 0
and there's just only a few nonzero
values
but it can also have fancier priors and
now we use data science methods
to do so
if you do it from hardware perspective
that is generally relevant for my
company sml
you generally see that a is constrained
by hardware because it has two
components one is the measurement value
the matrix phi this is hardware
dependent and psi is
more
data science algorithm related is a
transformation
not every a allows you to solve this
system this has to have some properties
and that property means that if you have
ks per signal so sigmas that are zero
everywhere but in k points in their
representation it should keep them
separate if two sigmas are
separate from each other after a is
applied they have to be separated and
you call that restricted isometry
property
and a can be a fully random matrix so
imagine that that the first time i saw
it is very surprising you get a signal
multiplied by random numbers
and what comes out of that is your
measurement
so you need actually measurements that
order
uh essentially uh for the number of
non-zero
uh elements and only grow linearly with
the number of pixels so if you have
millions of pixels this is logarithm of
millions of pixels it scales very
favorably in terms of the space that
you're solving so if you have a
statistics background this basically
solves a very high dimensional inference
problem very efficient
um
if you want a python example
a very simple case of that
is uh the k the the l1 reconstruction
that is actually in the scikit learn
there is a case of tomography the
construction with the oneprior
and that's a in case you can try out in
python and there are much more advanced
libraries as well
and asmr lots of times we do develop our
own algorithms because we have very
stringent
uh quality criteria we have very
stringent uh
timing criteria and that has to match
with our hardware
but for understanding the method this is
good so if i want to go to a more for
this
more formal description of the problem
you want to solve a linear system
and this is actually now
you want to minimize
the
number of non-zero elements in your
representation subject to your
measurements
are essentially
held so this means that you're solving
an a zero norm problem
and
this
most of the time ends up being an empty
heart problem so if n goes to infinity
the num the length of this vector x
essentially you cannot really solve this
using the standard computation things
looks like
finding a needle in a haystack so it's
possible but not really feasible soon it
becomes infeasible
the same argument that is often used in
cryptography as well um however there is
the magic called the one magic this is
essentially what really started this
field and put this name around 2006 and
this is if you have enough measurement
which means that your number of
measurement grows
with the number of non-zero elements as
well as the log of the space that you're
solving so the total number of pixels we
can solve this very difficult prior
with a much simpler prior so you have to
solve this l1
problem subject to your linear
constraints that are coming from
measurement and this is also finding a
needle in the hairstyle it's just the
needle is much bigger so now you have a
convex problem and this products can be
solved in polynomial time and there are
very powerful tools for it and there's
lots of proofs of convergence and very
very beautiful theory
so this really started the field
now an overview again
um
if i have
m measurements of some
object that has
k
non-zero elements if m h much
if m is less than k i essentially cannot
solve that problem this is impossible in
the information theoretic sense because
i have insufficient information and this
is like finding the black cat in the
dark room we as humans are very good at
it finding patterns they don't exist
um
and this is um
it gets slightly better if your number
of measurements your m increases after a
certain point so if m equals k now you
can solve this it's just very hard to do
that so it is computationally infeasible
you can solve it in a smaller scale in
larger scale you can't solve it if this
is just too much
hay then you cannot find this needle um
and then if you further increase the
number of measurements then this becomes
a simple problem right and this might be
trivial but it has a very interesting
connection to physics actually
uh
this is a 2d diagram called the phase
diagram k divided by n
is the probability of non-zero value so
here
every element of your representation has
a non-zero value and here everything is
zero here m divided by n is measurement
rate at one means that every pixel is
actually measured or the number of
measurements equals for example the
number of pixels
and here you basically made no measure
so
this is the region where you can't solve
you don't have enough measurements
this is the region that you can solve
but for different classes of signals and
now i just talked about the sparse
signal so this blue curve
between these two regions there is this
gap that l unknown doesn't work so in in
inference is infeasible and after that
you get another
phase transition which
allows you to do inferiors
these are by the way asymptotic results
they come from some
statistical physics theory and method
called directly committed and
yeah there's a very beautiful
relationship between these
phases of matter
uh
so here we have this inference problem
that is impossible hard and easy and
suppose the matter wants to go to the
crystal state so in the liquid they say
that just doesn't happen there is a
point that it can happen the material
the matter can go to to crystal state
but maybe it gets stuck in a in a state
the local minima of what you call free
energy
you can see free energy and uh
all over also the machine learning
literature for example in
auto encoders variational autoencoders
and then there is a point where it's
easy to find that crystal state it's the
same happening here and this is not a
pure analogy the mathematics of it is
the same so the mathematics that governs
interference and data science is the
same that mathematics are constantly
that governs the state of the matter
going back to the fact that signals are
not
sparse here again is the measurement
sorry the probability of getting a
non-zero value over some data set and
this is a histogram of the the amount of
non-sparsity so if you're here you're
very sparse and if you're here you're
really not sports at all and so you see
that a lot of images have
a large degree
of
more than say 30 percent or so
non-sparsity
um so natural signals are not really
sparse
and if i now mix this with this results
of the phase transition
that how much data you need such that
things work if you're in this region say
around 20 non-sparsity your measurement
rate can just be half so essentially you
can measure half the number of pixels
such routines work without any error
which doesn't look that good actually
so
this is where data science really
comes and brings value so suppose this
is in this numbers this is l1
reconstruction so using only a sparsity
and you see that with 25 measurements
that one reconstruction fails so it's in
in the region that there is no enough
information if you use neural networks
such as variational autoencoder or
uncertainty auto encoder you get much
better results and uncertainty auto
encoder is actually better than
variation encoder for this task because
it's developed for the compressive
sensing method
and essentially it's an auto encoder
where
the the encoder is a linear
system
and the decoder is non-linear and the
encoder is using information theoretic
arguments
about uh essentially what is the what is
the best direction to measure such that
uh the the the posterior uncertainty is
minimized
um this is a zoo of method actually just
up to 2017 so the data science standards
this is ancient times
uh i apologize for that but
that's not the point of this this this
uh
spectrum
what what you have seen in this spectrum
is
on one end of the spectrum you see uh
data efficient methods these are
interpretable they model physics some
sort of so these simple models there is
a whole lot of them developed in the
beginning
and then there are more advanced
handmade priors and here you see models
that are essentially
use deep learning they are they need a
lot of data
they have low bias they're very flexible
but they don't consider that you're
actually solving a um compressive
sensing problem per se really you don't
use the whole knowledge and the beauty
is in between where you go from
the marriage of physics based models and
data science based models to models that
are
mixing these two
so this is a whole set of different
uh essentially methods
and uh
uh and now i just basically said what is
the strategy that this method used so
this method three the problem was black
box
uh like a feed forward neural network
that does some reconstruction here you
have based on sparsity then you have
hand design priors and these are for
example you take a solver
and this solver is now
built to solve for example
this l1 norm
optimization problem and you unroll it
means that you kind of for example if
you have 10 steps of the solver you
create a 10 layer neural network and the
what each layer does
is
not a standard fit forward operation but
something that uses the equations of
essentially a solver for
uh for uh that one more minimization
then sometimes you model the priors or
the posteriors with with with
essentially a neural network so these
are the hybrid methods they have a lot
of value because they get the best of
both worlds there is some
interpretability in them by design and
they also can take advantage of the data
and then they can
get much better gains this is an example
of
learn that amp
essentially is called approximate
message passing this is an algorithm
works on graphs and
people use that montanari actually to
essentially build solvers for this l1
norm problem and
prove a whole lot of
very nice theoretical results
and what happens is that these operators
that generally happen in
this solver you replace them with neural
networks so you keep the equations of
amp
uh if you know about belief propagation
by the way amp is brief propagation
asteroids so so this is they use this
equations of a and p and just replace
some steps with a neural network that
you're going to train and these are
these hybrid methods
so
what happens here is that
deep learning is much faster more
accurate the problem is that it doesn't
come with really with guarantees so
this sometimes is a problem
depending on your application and
requirements of your customer
if it breaks how you want to service it
for example
but if i now look into different methods
and these are very powerful methods uh
these two methods are based on deep
learning
and you see here different measurement
rates
so here is a much higher measurement
rates you you have the number of
measurements is a quarter of the number
of signals
and here you have just 10 percent of the
total number of pixels you have
measurements
you see that
your pksnr
is here much better
in the case of the deep learning
and your reconstruction time also is
faster
because this neural network once trained
can can work much faster and this is
very important because we also sometimes
have timing constraints uh this is
actually the talk
uh i hope i was uh well in time and if
there is any questions i would
be happy to
to
take it thank you iman uh this was a
really informative presentation like i
really like the slides and i think we
have already we already have our first
question oh yeah it's about like are you
gonna share the slides it's a great
material
yes the slicer will be public
yes okay we'll share this slides
awesome so just to just to give context
to you and everyone that we have slack
channels like slack channel for
workshops and everything so there's a
slack channel called talks where you can
share your resources and ask your
questions for to the speaker and i think
we we have like a couple of minutes two
questions for take for taking questions
so if anyone has any questions please
feel free to drop them in chat or in the
q a section um okay yeah so just to just
to just to give attention to everyone
that asml is hiring across across
different roles so if you go on the
website and check out the job boards
they have listed uh
i think a bunch of bunch of roles which
basically intersect with data science
and physics and which is kind of
interesting and which is kind of
different from all the other job roles
that we have on our job board so yeah
feel free to check them out and you know
apply or maybe you can reach out to iman
during the conference if you have any
questions
yes please reach out
i will write down my uh
the asmr email
then you can contact me
we have a lot of interesting jobs at
this moment
for this particular application and many
other applications related to data
science there are many data science
teams in our company you may not have
heard of it but this is a if you use a
high-end phone
or actually even meat and phone
everything
you are using our products that are that
are building the the chips
in these systems so we would be very
happy to have you in our company
thank you
uh yeah iman so we have question from
simona
they're asking could you please give an
intuition of what an uncertainty auto
encoder is
it is something
uncertainty auto encoder is yeah so the
uae yes so uae is very much similar to
vae
um
but the linear
the the encoding is linear and the cost
function in design such that
which lin so suppose you have an object
and
for example think about pca pca tries to
find directions where the energy is
maximally spread so the variance is
maximum spread these are the
eigenvectors of your covalent matrix
that's pca but those directions are good
only for example if your
distribution is mostly like a caution if
you have two gaussians that are
orthogonal to each other
then the direction can be very very poor
then you want to have directions that
capture each mode separately in that
sense you a it would find those
directions it wouldn't necessarily go
for directions where data is most spread
it goes for a direction that's maximally
informative
and for informativeness we look into the
probability uh what we learn about the x
given the measurement y so it tries to
maximize the information of that
awesome thank you i think that answers
the question uh so uh there's another
question by uh
curating us jay i'm sorry if i if i
mispronounce your name the question goes
like how do you compare with
conventional method like stacking to
reduce noise
i'm not sure if i know what what he
refers to by stanking actually
uh i could i could give permission to
the to the question uh to the to the
list to the panel to the attendee if
they can ask questions uh let me let me
just do that
uh hi can you hear me
yes i can hear you but yes yeah yeah so
uh
in the past we we tried to get more data
from measurements that are actually
taking a lot more measurements and
and stacking the means like putting them
in the same domains like time domain
again and again
and with the hope of we getting more uh
[Music]
data signal rather than the noise yes i
tried to improve the signal to noise
ratio it's similar like we're taking
photography yes yes
yes yeah that's what we call stacking
yeah but this one you put a lot of more
with the computing
in deep learnings uh to to exactly
extra work uh prior to that so how do
you compare to non
very good question yes
do we have time to answer this now um so
uh yeah indeed the classical compressive
sensing has some robustness uh
considerations with respect to noise but
if you look at it very abstract
essentially
compressive sensing is nothing but
trading of one parameter with the other
for example you can make more
measurements
uh
trade some temporal resolution so you
take more time to take more measurements
and gain a spatial resolution for
example better noise and that's what you
call
stacking so even you can think of it
also as in this class of mathematical
models or you can go the other way so
depending on your application you may
want to trade some spatial resolution or
noise
and improve on your timing or the other
way around
pave in terms of time measure more and
improve on your
spatial resolution or noise performance
essentially compressive sensing just
allows exactly for this type of
trade-offs
but what most people
talk about in the industry about
compresses and seem to the answer i gave
you is this from mathematical
perspective they generally mostly refer
to the fact that you can save
for example some time
because for example mri time is the most
important thing
while maintaining a reasonable snr and
you can see that with deep learning
priors then the prior take care also all
part of the denoising because you know
where is your data manifold so you just
need to have enough information to point
to the correct
point on the manifold
yeah is it answering your question
uh yes yes so i see the the the function
of the prior okay thanks
awesome thank you
uh so seems like like we are almost at
the time uh we are just taught at the
time and uh yeah i would like to thank
man for coming today and you know uh
giving this awesome talk and you can
find iman on the slack uh you can just
search his name in the
directory and he
i'm sure iman you would be on the slack
to answer all the questions that
everyone has
and you could also share your slides on
talks channel it's it's hashtag talks uh
you can just upload the slides over
there
so thank you thank you man and yeah yeah
yeah thank you everyone